your first look at season 2 of The
Handmaid's Tale is here and it is
terrifying audiences will be happy with
what they're going to be served on
[Music]
Friday Hulu released these images from
the hit dramas highly anticipated second
season due out april 26 1 reveals what
appears to be the colonies often
reference to in season 1 as the place
that troublemakers in gilead society get
taken
[Music]
and here's Elizabeth mosses Offred
covered in blood
another shot shows a line of women
dressed in black garb with red masks a
stark contrast to the red and white
dress code that previously signified the
handmade status in gilead society et
caught up with Amanda Bruegel and
Madeline Brewer in September and they
teased what fans can expect from the new
season nothing is predictable nothing is
like the next step like the next logical
step as we would think it's really
throws you for a loop and keeps you
really interested it keeps you invested
in what's happening and it makes for
really freakin great TV season 2 is
going to make season 1 look like it was
just a walk in the park yeah you from
the first episode on like it from the
first for a shot first episode I'm
telling you get ready to start crying
[Music]